dee None,
but cool guys are irrational numbers, refreshing winds blowing through the grasslands,
or soil that relies on like a solid earth
In
addition to the four basic toxicities, it also has the same characteristics as
the members.Is it actually an amazing ability?It's a once-in-a-thousand-years-like
fire-attribute magic that
blocks the opponent's sight and blocks sound.
If it's a debuff totter hunter, it's only a slanting waterfall or a kana that's a blinding magic.
But the effect isn't that strong, so
I can use magic, too. Well,
it depends on the implementation.
The thing itself will come out of Subaru's gate. If
Riya's manners go out of control and Subaru explodes, her clothes will get dirty,
so stay away
.
It's okay
Now, try to imagine the flow of mana in your body
And then spit it out of your body from the panoramic gate